NEED THIS BED.
>> Tucker: WELL, THERE ARE A
LOT OF REASONS THAT MEN ARE
FALLING BEHIND IN THIS
COUNTRY.
LOOK AT THE NUMBER LOOKS AT
ONE STATISTICS THAT TRACKS THE
DECLINE OF AMERICAN MEN ALMOST
PRECISELY OVER TIME.
THE DISAPPEARANCE OF FATHERS
FROM THE HOME.
BETWEEN 1960-2016, THE
PROPORTION OF KIDS LIVING WITH
BOTH PARENTS DECREASED BY
ALMOST 20%.
THE PERCENTAGE OF CHILDREN
LIVING WITH ONLY THEIR MOTHERS
NEARLY TRIPLED.
IN DEMOGRAPHIC TERMS THIS IS
STUNNING.
CHANGES TO FAMILY STRUCTURE
THIS ABRUPT AND PROFOUND
TYPICALLY ARE ONLY SEEN IN
WARTIME.
YET IF ANYTHING IN THE NUMBERS
UNDERSTATE REALITY OF THE
FATHERLESSNESS IN AMERICA.
HIGH-END NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE
POLLY MAKERS -- POLICY MAKERS
LIVE, IT HASN'T CHANGED.
MOST GROW UP WITH THE FATHERS
AND THE MOTHERS BUT THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY INTACT FAMILIES
ARE DISAPPEARING.
ACCORDING TO A 2014 STUDY BY
RESEARCHERS AT JOHNS HOPKINS
UNIVERSITY AMONG YOUNGER
PARENTS WITHOUT COLLEGE
DEGREES 74% OF THE MOTHERS HAD
AT LEAST ONE CHILD OUTSIDE OF
MARRIAGE.
OUT-OF-WEDLOCK BIRTHS ARE NOW
THE RULE ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
NOT THE EXCEPTION.
HAVING A FATHER AT HOME IS A
SIGN OF AFFLUENCE BUT ALSO
CAUSE OF THE AFFLUENCE,
ESPECIALLY FOR BOYS.
BOYS WHO GROW UP WITH A FATHER
AT HOME EARN MUCH MORE AS
ADULTS.
BOYS WHO GROW UP ALONE WITH
THEIR MOTHERS TEND TO EARN
LESS.
THEY ALSO HAVE MORE
DISCIPLINARY PROBLEMS IN
SCHOOL.
THEY READ LESS AND LESS WELL
AND ARE LESS LIKELY TO
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL OR
GO TO COLLEGE.
THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
UNEMPLOYED AND LIVE IN
POVERTY.
THEY GET PARRIED LESS OFTEN.
WHEN THEY DO, THEY DIVORCE
MORE.
THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
OBESE AND HAVE ASTHMA.
THEY ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO
ABUSE ALCOHOL AND DRUGS,
EXHIBIT ANTISOCIAL BEHAVIOR
AND COMMIT ACTS OF VIOLENCE.
AS ADULTS THEY ARE TWICE AS
LIKELY TO GO TO PRISON.
THIS IS THE RESULTS OF
NUMEROUS STUDIES ACROSS
GENERATIONS THAT HOLD TRUE
ACROSS ETHNIC GROUPS.
BOYS RAISED WITHOUT THE FATHER
IS A TERRIBLE RISK.
THERE IS NOT MUCH DEBATE ABOUT
THAT.
IF ANY.
NATIONWIDE BREAKUP OF THE
FAMILIES IS A DISASTER.
NOT JUST A MORAL DISASTER BUT
A PRACTICAL ONE.
IT MAY BE THE LARGEST PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS WE FACE.
SO WHAT IS DRIVING IT?
THERE ARE MANY FACTORS.
FALLING MALE WAGES CERTAINLY
PLAY A ROLE.
WHEN MEN MAKE LESS THAN THE
WOMEN, WOMEN CONSIDER THEM
LESS ATTRACTIVE MARRIAGE
PARTNERS.